November or like November Netflix member
new one Netflix member whatever you want
to call it November 2019 is quickly
approaching and Netflix has announced
the movies and TV shows that will be
available to watch throughout the month
here's the best stuff hitting Netflix in
November 2009 teen Netflix subscribers
with a lover stand up will be treated in
a major way as the streamer is adding
four specials from some of the biggest
names in comedy on November 5th tuck
into Seth Meyers stand-up comedy special
lobby baby in which the late night host
discusses everything from being a father
to the reason why you should never take
your girlfriend to Paris for her
birthday filmed at Minneapolis is
Pantages Theater Seth Meyers lobby baby
is extra special for two reasons first
its Meyers his first ever Netflix comedy
special and second it takes its name
from the circumstances of the birth of
his second son Axl straw Meyers who came
into the world in the lobby of Meyers
apartment building a week later on
November 12th
Jeff Garlin one man in Chicago hits
Netflix this special is 12 special - it
was filmed in Garland's hometown of
Chicago 37 years to the day after he
debuted as a stand-up comedian and it
sees the Curb Your Enthusiasm actor take
a stroll down memory lane that's filled
with his quote signature blend of
storytelling and improv iliza shlesinger
v Netflix stand-up special unveiled will
arrive on the platform on November 19th
following after 2013's warpaint
2015's freezing hot 2016's confirmed
kills and 2018 elder millennial unveiled
seize the recently married Schlessinger
discussing all things wedding related
plus the quote dangers of a zombie
bachelorette army finally on November 26
Mike Birbiglia the new one will be
available to stream on Netflix in his
newest stand-up special for Biglia
Ponder's whether he's truly ready to
expand his family and bring a child into
the often terrifying modern world do you
like action franchises iconic Will Smith
and Martin Lawrence movies from the 90s
classic Bruce Lee martial arts films and
sequels while we'd say you have quite a
specific taste in cinema Netflix would
say it has you covered
coming to Netflix in November 2000 19 or
a handful of awesome action flicks like
1995's bad boys featuring Smith and
Lawrence as a pair of Miami detectives
looking into the disappearance of police
seized drugs you'll also be able to
catch 1973's Enter the Dragon the
beloved action ER for director Robert
Klaus that marked Ali's final film role
before his death all three entries in
the Bukowski's Matrix trilogy and 2017 s
Jumanji welcome to the jungle a
follow-up to the fantasy adventure
Jumanji from 1995 anyone who likes to
expand spooky season into November will
be in luck next month on Netflix as
three extra eerie flicks are hitting the
streamer on the 1st of the month
float up on roman polanski seminal
psychological horror feature Rosemary's
Baby
starring Mia Farrow as the titular
rosemary a pregnant woman who grows
suspicious that a satanic coven wants to
steal her baby for use in their evil
rituals on November 4th switch gears to
district 9 the Neill Blomkamp directed
sci-fi action thriller that takes place
in a South African internment camp known
as district 9 where insectoid aliens
that crashed on earth have been confined
a bit later on November 15th stream
Netflix's original thriller earthquake
berg a tokyo set mystery centered around
expat lucy fly the reasons why she's
suspected of killing her missing friend
lily and the charming photographer she
was romantically involved with escape
the drama of your everyday life by
diving into the immense already
critically acclaimed dramas heading to
Netflix the first arrival hitting the
streamer on November 1st is the king
based on a number of plays from William
Shakespeare's Henry at collection the
king tells the story of a prince who
rises to take the English throne and
become King Henry the fifth following
the death of his father a king that's no
only followers and fault
film opened in theaters for a limited
run on October 11th when critics took a
liking to it November 27th will see the
Netflix debut of Martin Scorsese's the
Irishman a gangster epic that chronicles
the life and crimes of Frank the
Irishman Sheeran a former mobster and
hitman long presumed to have had a hand
in the disappearance and suspected
killing of teams to remember Jimmy Hoffa
back then
there was nobody in this country who
didn't know who Jimmy Hoffa was like the
king the Irishman will have a limited
theatrical release prior to premiering
on Netflix critics have been praising
the Irishman since it debuted at the New
York Film Festival on September 27 but
audiences will have to wait until
November first to judge for themselves
then hold out a few weeks until it's
available on Netflix those looking for
non Netflix original dramas can dig into
David Ayres and watch on November 23rd
or Ridley Scott's all the money in the
world on November 30th Christmas will
come early for comedy lovers this
November on the first Netflix is adding
to its content catalog a number of
hilarious movies like stepbrothers and
wedding crashers the witty
post-apocalyptic flick zombie land and
even the subversive black comedy satire
Fear and Loathing in Las Vegas
well these fellas really let himself go
later in the month Netflix is really
rolling into the holiday spirit on
November 8 subscribers can stream let it
snow based on the New York Times
bestseller the film follows a group of
high school students as their lives
cross paths during a Christmas Eve
snowstorm snow I delight it's like this
space of weather window vember 15th
rolls around Netflix will add animated
comedy claws to its library followed by
the night before Christmas on November
21st
this Vanessa Hudgens starring flick sees
science teacher Brooke fall for sir Cole
a medieval knight transported to the
present day by a mystical sorceress
Netflix sure didn't forget about TV
enthusiasts though the streamer is
bringing a ton of amazing short form
content to subscriber screens in
November on November 1st you can stream
the Netflix original event American Sun
which follows a mother as she pieces
together the disappearance of her son
other standout TV additions include the
third season of atypical and the queer
eye special we're in Japan on November
1st it can't wait to rola participate
please okay the second season of the end
of the world and the fourth season of
Shira and the princess of power hit the
platform on November 5th while the fifth
volume of Patriot Act with Hasan Minhaj
premieres on November 10th and the third
season of the crown a week later on
November 17th
Netflix also has a few holiday specials
like season two of the great british
baking show holiday special on november
8th and season two of nailed it holiday
on November 22nd check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorites
topper coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]